[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal on passe le
titre en juin 2016 en couple de
policiers est assassinée chez eux à
magnanville par un terroriste un an
après une minute de silence et est
organisée ce matin à la préfecture de
versailles
hier le procès de deux militants de
l'association l214 jugé pour avoir caché
des caméras dans un abattoir de caudan a
été reporté plusieurs représentants de
la fédération départementale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles
manifestaient dans le devant le tribunal
de versailles
et puis après plusieurs mois de travaux
le nouvel accueil du public est fin prêt
à l'hôtel de ville de mort pas une
visite était organisée la semaine
dernière pour découvrir les nouveautés
c'était qu'il y a un an un couple de
policiers étaient assassinés à leur
domicile à magnanville par un
déséquilibré se revendiquant du groupe
de l'état islamique
un an après une minute de silence était
organisée au commissariat ce matin de
versailles pour leur rendre hommage
aujourd'hui c'est une cérémonie vous
l'avez vu empreinte de recueillement
dommage humbert leur collègue disparu en
même temps que se tient
une même cérémonie une cérémonie un peu
différente mais le même cérémonie dans
son principe à pézenas où elle repose
désormais et jean baptiste salvin
jessica schneider c'est un moment qui ne
s'effacera jamais de la mémoire de et
policiers des yvelines
ils étaient deux deux militants de
l'association l214 ces activistes qui
lutte contre la maltraitance animale et
la consommation de viande était jugé
pour avoir pénétré dans un abattoir la
fdsea manifeste manifestaient devant le
tribunal
ils étaient une cinquantaine des membres
de la fdsea et des agriculteurs devant
le palais de justice de versailles ils
manifestaient contre les méthodes de
l'association de protection animale l214
en décembre dernier deux de leurs
membres s'étaient introduits dans
l'abattoir dude en filmant notamment
l'étourdissement départ au co2 une
pratique malhonnête selon la fdsea
il ya deux choses qu'il faut bien
distinguer ya la violation de propriété
pour y installer des caméras
et puis il ya l'argument que met en
avant l'association l214 sur la
maltraite la soi-disant maltraitance des
animaux
en fait tous les éleveurs qui sont ici
qui sont ou se réunit aujourd'hui où
tous les éleveurs qui en font leur
métier
un seul souci en tête
au quotidien c'est bien évidemment le
bien-être animal c'est ce bien-être
animal il est encadré par la loi depuis
des décennies depuis les
dizaine d'années et ne s'arrête pas là
pour eux l'association l214 prônent avec
ses actions le véganisme et souhaite
tout simplement poussé l'opinion à ne
plus manger de viande donc la mort de
leur métier du côté de est de 114 ce
jugement va surtout permettre de mettre
le débat sur la table n'a un débat qui
je trouve à être intéressant entre le
travail d'une ong qui essayent de
témoigner des conditions d'élevage de
transport et d'abattoirs et d'abattage
des animaux
d'un côté la difficulté de rendre compte
de ces témoignages la difficulté
d'accéder aux lieux où sont tuer les
animaux puisque en l'occurrence là c'est
un abattoir et donc je suis vraiment
impatient il faudra attendre le mois de
septembre pour que ce débat puisse enfin
commencer
le procès a été reporté au 4 septembre
saviez vous que le nombre d'élèves
accueillis dans les établissements sous
contrat augmenté de manière
significative selon les statistiques de
la rentrée 2016
ils étaient six mille quatre cents
élèves de plus à s'asseoir sur les bancs
des collèges privés par exemple souvent
les parents cherchent une nouvelle
manière d'apprentissage ou encore un
encadrement différents regardez année
après année le succès de l'enseignement
privé se confirme
la proportion d'élèves de maternelle et
de primaire scolarisées dans
l'enseignement privé sous et hors
contrat a encore augmenté cette année et
est passé à 13 7%
quelles sont les raisons de ce choix
c'était plus ce départ
un choix de proximité par rapport à
notre domicile et aussi la réputation de
l'école qui avait une image plutôt des
cols familiale
de petites structures de petits
effectifs donc c'est ce qui nous avait
attiré en fait au départ ce succès n'a
plus grand chose à voir avec
l'instruction religieuse c'est la
qualité de l'encadrement qui est
plébiscité les familles sont attirés par
le fait que l'enseignement privé
s'efforce de construire un parcours
scolaire individualisé pour chaque élève
il ya d'autres familles qui viennent
plutôt pour nous confier des enfants
qu'il faut remettre en confiance avec le
système scolaire et ducati les
établissements hors contrat scolarise
moins de 1% des enfants mais leur nombre
va croissant
c'est souvent la promesse d'une autre
pédagogie qui attire les parents comme
c'est le cas par exemple pour les écoles
montessori en fait qu'il fallait
clarifier les choses qu'on attendait
j'allais tout valentin de voitures vélos
la philosophie montessori c'est que je
chacun doit apprendre à son rythme les
enfants évoluent dans une classe où il y
a le mélange des âges entre 3 et 6 ans
on tient compte en fin de compte de
leurs besoins et de leurs plans de
développement
ces écoles ne bénéficions d'aucune aide
de l'état elles doivent s'autofinancer
pour payer leurs locaux les salaires des
enseignants le matériel ce qui implique
des frais de scolarité très élevé pour
les familles un sacrifice on a changé un
projet en fait par rapport à ça pour
pouvoir justement faire ça à nos enfants
puissent confier un deuxième qui suit
juste moi qui va rentrer en septembre
donc c'est vrai choix de mire et des
écoles qui convienne à certains enfants
mais pas à d'autres
et aujourd'hui les parents n'hésitent
plus à faire des allers retours entre le
public et le privé
après des mois de travaux le nouvel
accueil du public est fin prêt à l'hôtel
de ville de mort pas une visite était
organisée la semaine dernière pour
découvrir les nouveautés
l'événement était suivie d'une
intervention du maire de la commune
grégory gare est-il visite guidée de la
mairie pour les habitants après plus de
huit mois de travaux les morlaisiens ont
découvert le nouvel espace d'accueil de
l'hôtel de ville une présentation
commentée par les agents municipaux les
bureaux soient indépendants tout ça au
point de vue
non je trouve ça très très bien au point
de vue éclairage et tous et pour
l'accueil je pense que ça sera mieux que
ça sera mieux qu'avant 1 mais c'est un
bonheur pour tous les usagers et puis
tous ceux qui vont travailler dans cette
mairie depuis de nombreuses années ils
vont pouvoir avoir le confort au
quotidien dit chez unique réorganisation
des services modernisation du matériel
informatique pour un investissement
global d'un million d'euros nous
développons de nouveaux outils sûr
l'internet est aussi l'accueil physique
est très important au travers de de
plusieurs modes d'organisation l'accueil
et aussi l'organisation même sur le
plateau du rez de chaussée avec des
modes de
d'organisation repenser une
réorganisation visible avec une
modification dans la structure des
bureaux et la mutualisation des services
en trois pôles poule citoyen paul
famille et pôle loisirs l'umq rénovation
qui permet d'apporter aux aux agents
meilleures conditions de travail et donc
avec ses meilleures conditions de
travail de mieux accueillir les usagers
l'ancien enfance éducation est devenu
pôle famille
il a regroupé du coup la vie scolaire la
l'enfance et la petite enfance pour la
cinquantaine d'agents municipaux de la
mairie de maurepas la transversalité
entre les pôles sera essentiel pour
servir efficacement les administrés et
on passe au sport avec le tournoi des
samouraïs il était organisé ce week end
au gymnase des droits de l'homme à
guyancourt cette compétition très
attendu du public est en partenariat
avec le club de judo de la commune
regardez je m'appelle mathieu
j'ai fait le tour n'a de judo à
guyancourt
j'ai une nouvelle ceinture comme mathieu
une centaine de judokas âgés de 4 à 12
ans participé ce dimanche ont joint au
traditionnel tournoi des samouraïs à
guyancourt
une compétition organisée chaque année à
la fin de l'année scolaire par le club
local au gymnase des droits de l'homme
est déjà en fait pour
remerciez récompensé au moyen du passage
de grade de ceinture supérieure
les élèves qui ont été les plus assidus
qui ont eu des résultats en compétitions
tout au long de l'année les compétitions
qu'on fait nous dans les yvelines
on récompense aussi
quelques élèves vraiment élus triés sur
le volet on le récompense pour leur
assiduité leur concentration bien
qu'amical esprit de compétition était
bien présent chez les petits judokas
tous ont voulu enchaîner les ippons et
les wazari pendant leur combat à la fin
de la journée les organisateurs ont
récompensé les meilleurs sportifs avec
des médailles
j'ai trouvé vieux j'ai fait plus gérer
ses biens quoi en gagnent mais quand on
perd c'est aussi parce qu'on a soit des
adversaires plus forts ou soit parce
qu'on n'a pas bien combattu
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition le tournoi des
samouraïs bleus en cours histoire qui
dure depuis une vingtaine d'amis et en
mots de rugby à présent plaisir n'ira
pas en demi finale du championnat de
france de fédérale 3 les hommes de jean
mi se sont inclinés contre tours sur
terrain neutre à nogent le rotrou
après avoir raccroché leur adversaire 9
à 12 pendant une grande partie du match
les plaisirs ont craqué dans les dix
dernières minutes pour finalement
s'incliner 24 à 9
malgré cette défaite les airs évoluera
la saison prochaine dans le championnat
de fédérale 2
l'heure était aux activités
scientifiques à lille 2-2 de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
les plus jeunes ont pu découvrir
question de science enjeux citoyens au
carré une exposition qui se veut ludique
interactive dimanche dernier l'atelier
était dédiée aux cerfs-volants invisible
mais indispensable à toute forme de vie
l'air s'installe au coeur d'une
exposition sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines le climat la
respiration ou encore les odeurs
plusieurs thématiques sont abordées pour
comprendre l'interaction entre l'homme
et l'air une exposition aussi
pédagogique interactive les yvelines
sont la dernière étape d'un voyage
débuter en 2016 et qui a parcouru toute
l'île de france
cette exposition elle est pas figée au
fur et à mesure des deux mois
d'installation
on espère je pense que ça devrait bien
arriver que les gens qui vont visiter
vont avoir envie de participer et de
s'exprimer
à l'intérieur de cette exposition
soutenue notamment par la région
l'exposition a déjà été visitée par
quarante mille personnes
puis un an et demi ce jour-là à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
l'atelier pour les enfants est consacrée
aux cerfs-volants
s'il n'y a pas de vent et le cerf-volant
va toujours rester par terre il ne va
pas voler alors que le vent il va tenir
le cerf-volant
dans les airs et puis ça va voler ça va
bouger
m l'expo qui inspirait à découvrir
jusqu'au 30 juillet à saint quentin en
yvelines et dimanche prochain une après
midi spécial sera consacré au
réchauffement climatique
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis prochain numéro
demain à 18 heures bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]